this trade online mostly on Facebook
Marketplace is where people forage for
formula
it involves open tubs of baby milk being
sold or given away
it was called out as part of a Sky News
investigation into what the high prices
in the shops are really doing to
families
but Emily at the Hartlepool baby Bank
sees no change online those open tubs
will be ladent with bacteria without a
doubt they're not sealed they're not
secure and those babies who have them if
it's not sterilized properly we'll get
sick the president of global Affairs at
Meadow which runs Facebook is Nick Clegg
the former deputy prime minister we
asked to speak to him about formula but
meta didn't respond my plea to the likes
of Nick Clegg who know these families he
does know them they were once his
constituents is to do more just put a
few basic programming Tools in and and
do something not words actions after Sky
News flag just one example of an open
tub of formula for sale meta said we
don't allow the sale of infant
nutritional formula on Facebook
Marketplace and will continue to remove
listings that break our rules like we
did in this case at 16 months old Caleb
is now moving on to solids his mother
paisy saw our investigation and has now
raised over a thousand pounds to buy
formula milk for struggling families she
too is furious about the online trade
that's putting infants at risk social
media platforms and you know people like
meta they have so much
um they have so much control over this
situation they play a big role in this
and they need to actually acknowledge
that and realize that they can change
this they are part of the problem
families doctors Charities and some MPS
all say they want this danger eliminated
the ads may break Facebook's rules but
they are still there
Tom palminter Sky News